orlando martínez
I am 25 years old I
work for you to save them the same for 25
years
I am a food server
[Music]
if we are still a lot without working
we are worried because if
they all removed us by law because of the
situation we are in from what came from the
virus we are  worried because we
don't want to lose our jobs that they
will kick us all out
and that when it gets worse in six months they will
kick all my colleagues out and not
give them their jobs with all the honor they
have and when the year is over they won't kick
everyone out
now  we are not working because there is
no let's say that the virus is still
there if the business is not still operating
the businesses are still not full
let's say
I am here to support myself and my
colleagues support the union and we want to
keep our jobs because
we have a lot of seniority and obviously  We
don't want to lose that thing about them kicking us
all out and starting from scratch. I think we
have the right with all the
companies. I don't know.  I expected
and we want to keep
because then we are thousands of
people without work
they say well we have to go out and look for
work
let's say we are not 500 we are
many I cannot tell you there are many
we are putting the right
this is going to make them realize
that we are fighting for  our
rights I believe that as one beings
as workers as members of the
union we have the right to keep
our jobs
to me
to many friends nothing more but it is already like
family after so many years
we have the right to return to
work now
support all the unions that are
[Music]
that is going to help us who are
employees I am here once in
I have been working for several years
so I just want you to know it's
not just me but it's blood thousands of
people who are
working have already lost their jobs and right
now  that the six months
of the union contract elapse we will no longer have a
job
my father who is still in the hospital with
cover that they have  given many of their years to
these companies
and keeping their job
not just me but all my co-
workers are a family we go for the best
possible service they come
back and come back convinced them
why employees like me who give them the
best service do not go  to have in
no other place in no other
all of us who are here we all want
the same thing we want our
voices to be heard we want them to be in the contract for two years so that we are
not going to lose our
jobs to the neighborhoods employees who
changed to the form of another department
that  Now they have lost their job and they will no longer
have a job and they could not even
start and they have already left a job
to go to another department so that
they can be fired later
what we want is for them to hear our
voices and help us